[Music]
[Applause]
albert brier senior nfl reporter lead
strategist for the monday morning
quarterback he joins us on the program
albert thanks for joining us
why was urban fired last night
i think it just reached the point of no
return dan i mean like the bottom line
is um you know after
everything that happened over the course
of the last you know two months going
back to october
um you know i think the question shot
khan had to ask himself was are people
in this building still responding to
urban meyer um and you know sometimes
perception can become reality and um you
know i i think one the you know report
from nfl.com you know tom pellicer did a
great job with that last week um you
know when that surfaces and you know
then you have um you know the former
kicker josh lambo coming out and saying
what he said to rick stroud um yesterday
you know the green light's on for
everybody who has an issue everybody has
an axe to grind to come out and say
something about it and at that point you
know the question becomes
is this the right environment for our
young players to be in over the next
month
and clearly you know the answer to that
question for shad khan was no the
situation was untenable going forward
and that's why he had to make this move
what do you think's going to happen with
that contract
it's a great question because i don't
know like i don't know you can fire him
for cause for the lambo thing because i
mean like logistically and i'm not a
lawyer but like logistically i look at
it and it happened in august and if it
happened in august and shad khan knew
about it and decided to go forward with
him and let him coach out three quarters
of an nfl season
then in his mind did it really like rise
to the level of a fire
for cause sort of offense
logic would tell you no um so
i mean my guess is behind the scenes
some sort of settlement has worked out
and that maybe we never hear about that
but
um you know i don't know that they can
really fire him for cause based on what
we've seen to this point um and based on
what we know to this point as unhealthy
as that building was i mean the one
thing that i think would maybe
potentially rise that level was
something that that that happened in
august and that according to all
accounts the owner knew about right
after it happened
who's more likely to get another job
first urban or john gruden
i don't think you're going to work in
the nfl again uh um i mean i'll just be
honest well urban urban can't but
college
yeah and i just i like so i talked to
urban about this in the summer dan and
i didn't sense a great desire
to
go back to college and i think the main
reason why is because i think recruiting
had worn him out um i think the 24 7
nature of it you know has sort of become
an issue for him as he had gotten older
and i think any coach that's moved from
college to the nfl would tell you you
know one of the biggest benefits is
getting away from basically having to
live your life 24 7 through a phone at
the whims of 16 and 17 year olds because
recruiting controls who wins and loses
at that level you know and so
um i i don't know that he would want to
dive into the world of recruiting not to
mention what it's become since he left
with nil with the transfer portal and
everything else and so
um you know maybe like that's just you
know his obsession with competition
pushes him back into it but i think if
you asked him right now he'd probably
tell you he's probably coached his last
game yeah i just don't see it you know
these guys are so
ego maniacal and yeah i mean he's only
57 he might appear to be
an unhealthy 57 but he's still only 57
and i don't know these guys all think
they can fix something i mean the
question the other question though dan
is right like who's going to hire him at
this point like
like and look like we've seen cases
where guys have gotten back up on their
like hugh freeze got back on his feet
right bobby petrino got back on his feet
so we've seen examples of it
but does urban want to take a step back
because i don't know
like would usc hire him right now no you
know what i mean would texas hire him
right now so him going back to college
coaching what like what level would that
require him going in on you know and
does he want to do that like if he
doesn't have the stage of an ohio state
or a florida does he want to go back and
coach it and i don't know i'll throw a
name out there a like in iowa state you
know what i mean or an oregon state like
does he want to do that i
i don't know it's hard for me to see
because you know if recruiting was an
issue for him when he was at ohio state
boy let me tell you it's it's not going
to be easier if you're going to one of
those like tier 2 power 5 jobs much less
some sort of mid-major and i could see a
scenario where ryan day eventually goes
to the nfl
yeah luke fickle takes over at ohio
state yeah you know because i've already
had a couple of people say could you see
urban if ryan day left going back to
ohio state and i go i don't see that
i i would think that they would look at
luke fickle before they would or matt
campbell i mean like i like there are
people who would line up there are young
people who i i think would line up for
that job luke fickle certainly has the
respect of a lot of people um in that
place and you know i think he would be a
candidate and matt campbell i can tell
you for a fact dan i don't know if this
is even out there but in 2019 2018 2019
before they turned to ryan day they took
a very very hard look at bringing matt
campbell over from iowa state before
deciding to go with ryan day so there
are a couple of guys in fickle and
campbell who are from ohio where that
would qualify as their dream job that i
think that that ohio state would
probably go to before they go back to
urban now that said
he was an administrator at ohio state
right and you know he's obviously still
close with ryan day so does the
possibility exist that maybe he goes
back in some sort of administrative role
to ohio state helps ryan day out i think
that's possible
how attractive is the jacksonville job
uh
you know
i think it was way more attractive a
year ago because a year ago
you had you knew you were getting trevor
lawrence so in either case 2021 2022
you're getting trevor lawrence
last year you had a blank slate you had
all the cap space you had all the draft
picks
and you don't have all that this time
around now like the the draft picks are
on the roster but you don't get to make
those picks yourself some of the cap
money spent so you don't get to spend
that yourself
um you know so
and there are those drawbacks i don't
think the location's the most
most most attractive to a lot of coaches
going and living in jacksonville florida
have to attract players to jacksonville
florida that's not the most attractive
that's not the the best situation in the
league
um and then you know i mean the owner
hasn't shown that he can win i mean
let's call it what is and i think we all
like shot khan is he more successful
than jimmy haslam right now
no he's an owner no right like like
where would he rank like based on what
he's done in 10 years where would he
rank like near the bottom right so like
i think you have to add all those things
together that said
there's still a chance to work with
trevor lawrence right like there's still
a young roster with promising young
pieces on it travis etienne we'll see
what he becomes you got josh allen on
the defensive side of the ball um you
got some veteran pieces like miles jacks
so like there's something to work with
there and i think because of the
quarterback's attractive but i don't
think it's quite as attractive as it was
a year ago
i was wondering
byron leftwich
yeah
buck's offensive coordinator i mean
imagine if tom brady today
had a you know press conference and just
said you know hey i don't know what
jackson gonna do jacksonville's gonna do
but you know
i i would hate to lose byron leftwich
but he's gonna be a head coach one like
i don't know maybe if you jump start
that talk uh if eric b enemy would get a
chance here brian dable who's done a
great job like you got to get somebody
who's going to develop trevor lawrence
and that's i mean that's the main thing
right like i think you're sort of in the
same situation as the rams were in 2016.
and
that was a dysfunctional mess on the
level of this like the rams were
like after their first year in los
angeles coaching didn't get along with
the front office jeff fisher gets fired
with the month clubs in the season jared
goff looked god-awful and you remember
this dan in year one right and so
everything for them was like how do we
get things right in general but like how
do we create the right environment for
our young quarterback that we drafted
first overall
and what do they do well a lot of people
said you need an experienced guy to come
in and clean this up they went in the
opposite direction they went completely
in the other direction and maybe picked
a guy that you know it was a year or two
early you know at least on paper and it
winds up being like as big a home run of
a higher as we've seen in the last 10
years in sean mcvay so like i think the
idea of bringing in a young guy who can
energize your building who can
revitalize your young quarterback is
good
byron left which is a good name you
mentioned brian dabal that's another
good name i'd throw kellen moore the
cowboys offensive coordinator who's
helped bring dak prescott along he's a
good name i also wouldn't rule out and
this one's going to be i know that this
is sort of a divisive one josh mcdaniels
i mean like you look at what he's done
with mac jones in trevor lawrence's
draft class right and it's not just mack
jones if you look in his history develop
matt castle into a quarterback who won a
division title with another team
developed jimmy garoppolo into a
quarterback who went to a super bowl
with another team developed jacoby
brissett into a guy who's probably going
to spend 10 years in the nfl he's got
great track record with quarterbacks
he's been a head coach before and i will
say this too
shad khan tony khan that ownership group
they listen to bill belichick one of the
reasons doug marone wound up going from
interim coach to full-time head coach in
2017
is because bill belichick told the cons
this guy can do it so they've got
history of going to belichick belichick
sort of owes josh mcdaniels one after
what happened a couple years ago with
the giants job and the panthers job so
it wouldn't surprise me if bill
belichick went to bat for josh mcdaniels
with jacksonville and it's not the
craziest idea because josh mcdaniel's
history of developing quarterbacks
is i think at an exemplary level what
about doug peterson who
yeah won a super bowl and just
disappeared
right and there are some interesting you
know like retread names that i think
you're going to hear and you know a lot
of them are on the defensive side of
ball quite quite honestly like raheem
morris todd bowles um dan quinn like
those are all good names that i think
you're going to hear kind of go through
the cycle um this year
like i think doug peterson's another one
that's a good name and you know
obviously like carson once benefited
early in his career now you know one
sideways later on but you look early in
his career doug peterson was able to
build a staff and bringing in like frank
reich as his offensive coordinator and
john d filippo as his quarterbacks coach
a staff that was able to support the
young quarterback and they got him
playing at an mvp level by year two and
i know that team you know didn't go to
the super bowl with carson once but they
went to the super bowl with car with
with the team that carson once was an
mvp candidate for so i think doug
peterson is a name that you kick around
and and and makes a lot of sense and the
beauty of it dan here's the thing
they've got a month now you know before
you know the the before we get to black
monday and they're even allowed to hire
somebody and so
i think you look at it if you're them
this gives you the chance to cast a wide
net you don't need to focus on first
first chance guy retread guy defensive
guy offensive guy they've now got the
time to cast that wide net and look at
whoever they want to look at what's the
current state of uh
in the nfl and are any games in jeopardy
and well it's it's interesting because i
don't think
so
like
the nfl will tell you that they're not
considering postponing games um i think
it's gonna be much harder it'll be much
harder to move games this year than it
was last year mainly because you got
fans in the stands like last year
yeah is there a forfeit policy
the forfeit yes but the forfeit policies
only goes into effect if the spread
within a building can be traced to an
unvaccinated player in other words like
if i'm unvaccinated and i bring it into
the office
like then the team can be held
responsible for that if the players who
have passed it around are vaccinated
then the league has said they'll do what
they can to accommodate everybody
i mean i think they're going to do what
they can to to get these games played
part of the issue though dan you know dr
alan sills the the chief medical officer
for the league went in front of the
owners yesterday and basically said to
them this is omicron that's why this is
happening with the rams that's why it's
happening with the browns and the
problem we have right now this is more
contagious than the previous strains but
it's also got milder effects so
basically you're seeing something that's
probably going to spread a little easier
but it's going to have less of an effect
on the people involved and that's why
they've gone to the union and they're
talking to the union about finding a way
to change the protocols and make maybe
significant changes to the protocol so a
couple ideas that have been discussed
one is incentivizing the booster and if
you get this to say to players if you
get the booster then you don't have to
test anymore i don't think that one's
going to happen a second idea that i i
think makes maybe a little more sense is
if you test going back to daily testing
and then if a guy tests positive and
he's asymptomatic and he's vaccinated he
can stay in the building he just has to
mask and distance and he can play
because there's been no evidence of
on-field transmission of the virus one
way or another with how quickly this
spread between the brown situation the
ram situation and really all seven of
the teams that are in intensive
protocols right now i think the league
is concerned that this is the tip of the
iceberg and they are going to be put in
certain circumstances where you could
have a situation like you had last year
in denver with the quarterbacks or new
orleans with the running backs
great stuff albert thanks as always for
joining us
you got it dan albert breer senior nfl
reporter lead content strategist for the
monday morning quarterback
always smarter when albert comes on